dez milhões de pessoas
nós seres humanos seremos 10 milhões de
habitantes nesse planeta em 2050 segundo
a onu a alimentar essa população e
iremos precisar de aumentar o cultivo em
70 a 100 por cento
hoje como que se cultiva hortaliças e
alimentos no mundo
quem sabe alguém sabe quando que foi a
última vez que soube do agricultor que
cultiva alface que você se alimentar
ontem o tomate
alguém sabe de onde veio o tomate pode
levantar a mão quem sabe de onde veio o
tomate que aumentou ontem não é do
mercado tem certeza
mais do que isso precisa ser mais
produtivo para ser mais produtivo
a gente precisa lembrar que a
agricultura consome 70% da nossa água
37% da nossa terra
responsável pelo consumo de 30% da
energia e emite gases de efeito estufa
a gente pára para pensar um pouquinho
2050 já acha que vai ter mais ou menos
terra agricultável no mundo
tenho certeza que a resposta é -
precisamos ser mais produtivos
esse é o retrato do cultivo de
perecíveis no brasil
eu perguntei de onde vocês consomem
hortaliças
isso daqui é o que acontece todos os
dias no ceasa na sua casa e no campo e
se essa cadeia produtiva em mais de 5 é
luz é isso que acontece
o produtor que produz alface rúcula
agrião tomate pepino pimentão berinjela
e outros produtos perecíveis está a mais
de 200 quilômetros daqui
segundo a embrapa no brasil 54 repetir a
gente 54% de tudo que é produzido é
desperdiçado
a gente está gastando o dobro de terra
mais do que o dobro de terra para
alimentar a população sem contar aqui no
brasil quase 40 milhões de pessoas têm
só um prato de comida faz sentido pra
alguém nesse auditório esse número é uma
insensatez moderna é o que a gente fez
vivemos em cidades dois terços da
população mundial vivem cidade
a gente produz no campo a quase 200
quilômetros de onde a gente consome por
isso que a gente precisa repensar como a
gente consome e produz alimentos
perecíveis sabia quantos por cento do
valor que você paga um pé de alface vai
produtor do preço 30% trinta por cento
chegando a mão do produtor sabe que isso
acarreta acarreta mais o uso de
agrotóxicos
o brasil é o sétimo país consumidor de
agrotóxico por área plantada no mundo
o produtor de hortaliças ou de qualquer
outro produto precisa forçadamente
investirem agrotóxico pra poder aumentar
a sua produtividade e ficar com apenas
30% do valor do produto
mas calma nada disto é perdido temos
solução por isso que as fazendas urbanas
existem
eu sou o primeiro verdureiro o
fazendeiro urbano
um dos primeiros verdureiro fazendeiros
urbanos da américa latina
produzimos hortaliças dentro da cidade
você deve estar se perguntando agora se
é capaz de produzir hortaliças dentro da
cidade mas aqui a nossa primeira fazenda
urbana
ela está dentro de um shopping center em
belo horizonte
essa aqui é a segunda fazenda urbana
ela estava uma fábrica de automóveis
do outro lado da anhanguera
é possível produzir dentro da cidade em
espaços não utilizáveis muito mais do
que no campo
para se ter uma idéia o que essa fazenda
produz no campo precisaria de 30 mil
metros quadrados ou três maracanãs está
falando aqui de mil metros quadrados em
cima de uma laje de um espaço não
utilizável anteriormente com a companhia
e hidroponia o que isso quer dizer
é o xixi e cocô da planta junto quando
chegou do peixe junto com nutrientes que
dá o nutriente pela planta crescer nessa
estufa controla umidade temperatura e
luminosidade bh para dar o melhor
nutriente e espaço e ambiente para a
planta crescer
somos 28 vezes mais produtivos que o
óbito agricultura convencional e
utilizamos 90% menos água do que o
cultivo convencional e pasmem estamos a
100 metros de distância do restaurante
que consomem essas hortaliças todos os
dias
imagine o frescor o sabor que isso daqui
pode transformar numa salada uma
conscientização e no aumento de consumo
de hortaliças próprios colaboradores de
uma fábrica
vamos pensar mais adiante
podemos imaginar um futuro a onde a
gente consiga produzir hortaliças em
espaços totalmente fechados como um
auditório um prédio ou até mesmo debaixo
do solo já é possível produção com led
indoor que consegue atingir 300 vezes
mais produtividade do que um produtor
convencional
isso é realidade em seu futuro
é como a gente vai ficar mais produtiva
e alimentar 10 bilhões de pessoas
mas vamos voltar um pouco vão votar na
essência do ser humano
imagine uma criança que faz cara feia
para a salsinha que enfeita o prato ou
não sabe de onde o pé de alface que está
no prato dela foi produzido mais do que
isso faz birra para comer verde
essa criança pode visitar uma estufa que
está do lado da casa dela
essa criança ela está sendo
conscientizada como cultivar como ser
mais sustentável e como alimentar 10
milhões de pessoas sem deixar ninguém
passar fome fazendo urbana é isso é
impactar é produzir esses mais
sustentável perto de casa perto da
cidade dentro de um shopping dentro de
uma fábrica ou até mesmo no prédio é
possível fazer isso hoje
obrigado
[Aplausos]